of the roughly 7 000 languages spoken
and signed on earth about 500 of them
are currently at risk of disappearing as
the number of native speakers dwindles
this is the story about one man
dispatching an army of volunteers to
record these languages before it's too
late
my name is daniel and i am the
co-founder and director of wikitongs a
non-profit powered by more than a
thousand volunteers around the world
working to preserve promote and pass on
every language to the next generation
every day hundreds of volunteers around
the world are recording videos
[Music]
i help keep track of all of these videos
as they're submitted so that they can be
reused for educational and cultural
purposes
new york is very important to linguistic
diversity new york is by most statistics
the most linguistically diverse city in
the world there are as many as 800
languages spoken in and around the five
boroughs in many cases it can be easier
for communities to maintain their
languages here than it is to maintain
their languages at home
[Music]
today we're going to meet up with
wikiton's volunteers who are going to be
taking us through different parts of new
york
[Music]
[Music]
so we're going to speak ilocano
yeah
[Music]
wikiton's focuses on recording oral
histories which is a fancy way of saying
talking about yourself and your culture
sometimes people barely talk about their
language at all and they just talk about
their daily job in their language of
course
sometimes people talk about the history
of their language and their culture
my name
is i will speak aru language
the wikitung's approach is record
everything and classify it later what i
do is make sure that all of that content
gets tracked and archived so it doesn't
get lost and so it can be used for
posterity and in the long term
ecommerce
has recorded over 435 languages from
over 70 countries
that number changes every day
there are plenty examples of languages
being brought back from the dead there's
cornish there's hebrew there's tunica
all of these languages had one thing in
common when the last native speaker died
there were materials for the cultural
descendants to bring them back and so
building an open archive of every
language in the world is not just a way
of ensuring that people today can
promote and teach their languages
to the next generation it's a way of
ensuring that future generations can
revive their languages even if they go
extinct
[Music]